[Music]
Disney is sneaky seriously there are so
many connections between movies and we
bet you never knew about them stay tuned
for the ultimate connection that will
make you go back and re-watch every
movie to catch it don't forget to give
this video a thumbs up and subscribe to
the things now let's get to the video
Finding Nemo and The Incredibles well
sort of not The Incredibles the movie
since Finding Nemo came out a year
before the actual movie but this
connection is still adorable and plenty
of people have missed it remember the
scene in the dentist office where you
see a young boy in the waiting room with
his mom
they're both reading their papers but if
you pay attention to what the boy's
reading you'll see that it's the mr.
incredible comic it's definitely mr.
incredible ahead of his time and way
ahead of his iconic red suit but perhaps
this is a clue all along since the
Incredibles came out a year later no
idea but that was a clever one up and
Toy Story 3 it's strange how many Pixar
Easter eggs you can find and other Pixar
and Disney movies
it looks like the creators are really
having fun with these and of course it
makes our videos that much more
interesting up came out in 2009 but did
you know that it featured the lot so
hugging bear from Toy Story 3 Toy Story
3 didn't even come out until 2010
so again is this just another prediction
most of us missed at the time they
really know how to play with our minds
go re-watch the scene where the balloons
pass a child's window the pink bear from
Toy Story 3 is featured in the left
bottom corner Toy Story 2 and bug's life
speaking of Toy Story the second movie
also has several Easter eggs you've
probably never noticed before miss
Potato Head reading the story is a cute
moment but have you seen what stories
she's actually reading it's very hard to
miss this detail and it's definitely not
a common connection but check out this
shout out to the bug's life does the
picture look familiar
it's the only clue we have but we're
pretty sure this is yet another Disney
Easter egg Toy Story 2 only came out a
year after the box life so it makes
total sense that Disney gave bug's life
another shout out
cars and other movies there are actually
plenty of Easter eggs and cars and
they're so subtle you can easily miss
them you can find plenty of Disney
movies being advertised on those side
road advertisements if you paid enough
attention you'd probably notice a sign
called toy car story which is an obvious
reference to Toy Story or The
Incredibles
which is a shout out to the Incredibles
these are usually placed in the
background why the camera focuses on the
actual cars driving but rewind the
scenes and we're sure you'll be able to
catch some of the same references have
you noticed that the credits of cars
also feature bug's life
sneaky several movies we'll talk more
about how multiple Disney movies are
connected with each other for the next
few minutes because there are so many
moments you've never noticed does this
ball look familiar to you it's just a
random ball right nothing special
looks like something that just easily
blends in a playroom well it turns out
that this ball blends in so easily
Disney managed to fit it in plenty of
your favorite movies including up
Monsters Inc The Incredibles Toy Story
and plenty more just pay attention to a
yellow ball with a red star we promise
you'll be able to suddenly see it
everywhere even more movies no seriously
almost every Disney movie is connected
with each other keep on watching to see
the ultimate connection that brings
these movies together if you saw Coco
you probably noticed a Pizza Planet
truck zooming past at the beginning of
the movie well you can actually find the
Pizza Planet truck in every single
Disney movie out there except for the
Incredibles it's a totally fake delivery
service but for some reason Pixar
decided to include it in every movie
ever made and believe it or not that's
not the only connection that brings all
Disney movies together the best one will
be revealed at the end more Toy Story 2
and bug's life ever notice this one if
you rewatch the Toy Story 2 scene where
the gang is looking for woody you'll
notice that buzz runs past some really
familiar characters do you see it you
can see flick from Bug's Life lay it on
the ground but in one of the earlier
scenes you also sees six other
characters hanging on the wall we're not
sure what's with all the bug's life
references but it looks like the Toy
Story 2 team felt really nostalgic after
and of bugs for so long and they just
really couldn't let it go we bet there
are plenty of more bug's life references
in Toy Story movies ratatouille and up
here's another funny one in case you're
not convinced that every single Disney
movie has a connection it's even funnier
when you realize the movies weren't even
released at the same time
ratatouille was made two years before up
and what it looks like Doug the dog was
already designs back then because you
can clearly see it in the scene where
Remi gets chased by Gaston he's
disguised as the shadow on the wall but
it looks nothing like Remi and it
definitely doesn't look anything like a
stove we know it takes a long time to
animate movies but it still takes us by
surprise when we catch things like these
Monsters Inc and Finding Nemo if you
dare to watch the final scene of
Monsters Inc go ahead because there's a
secret easter egg you probably missed
after Bruce dies by - Mike Wazowski she
starts hanging Sulley her toys you can
see Woody from Toy Story but you can
also see MIMO the adorable toy makes a
squeaky noise before it's handed in to
Sully's arms Finding Nemo came out two
years after Monsters Inc and this is
just another proof that every single
Disney movie is connected with each
other and if you still don't believe
that this is true here's the ultimate
proof every Disney movie okay so
seriously all Disney movies share the
same thing and it's not luck so balls or
Pizza Planet trucks well it's also those
but there's another connection you might
not know of did you know that there's a
voice that connects every Disney movie
ever it's John Ratzenberger a voice
actor who's also known as the good luck
charm he was in every single movie you
could think of even though he played
minor characters most of the time
remember the voice of Hamm in Toy Story
it's the same voice as the Underminer
from name credible z' and many more
characters every Disney movie has a
connection and his name is John
Ratzenberger and that's all for our
video don't forget to subscribe to the
things and tell us how you felt about
this video thanks for watching and see
you next time
[Music]